hallo leute heute geht es um die
geschlechter im deutschen wie ihr wisst
gibt es drei artikel die ist der
weibliche artikel der ist der männlich
artikel und das ist das neutrum und
viele leute die deutsch lernen haben
eine sehr lange zeit probleme damit die
nomen mit den artikeln zu lernen also
man muss immer wissen welcher welches
nomen welchen artikel hat damit man sie
auch richtig im satz deklinieren kann
heute wollen wir euch ein bisschen damit
helfen aber soviel vorab leider gibt es
keine regel mit der man 100 prozent für
jedes nomen den artikel bestimmen kann
aber es gibt ein paar kleine regeln und
wenn man die kennt dann hilft das schon
mal für sehr viele worte und die werden
wir euch heute zeigen vorab etwas
generell es nur 13 prozent aller worte
haben zwei verschiedene geschlechter
oder haben mehr als 1 zum beispiel der
laptop und das laptop
das passiert vor allem bei wörtern die
aus anderen sprachen übernommen wurden
die meisten wörter haben jedoch nur
eingeschränkt und das müsst ihr
unbedingt lernen etwas interessantes
vielleicht für euch 46 prozent aller
worte sind feminin 34 prozent aller
worte maskulin und nur 20 prozent aller
worte haben einen neutralen artikel und
jetzt zeigen wir euch die regeln mit
denen ihr euch zumindest einige worte
merken könnte wir zeigen euch jetzt eine
liste mit regeln bzw eine liste mit
endungen die immer auf ein feminines
wort schließen lassen
das erste ist worte die auf händen sind
immer feminin zb die datei die bäckerei
oder die polizei an
die distanz die toleranz die bilanz
die konferenz die existenz die tendenz
auch alle worte mit hide und kite am
ende sind immer eher weiblich zum
beispiel die freiheit die krankheit die
sicherheit die schwierigkeit oder die
geschwindigkeit worte mit ie am ende die
demokratie
die studie oder die energie worte die
auf igg enden sind auch immer feminin
zum beispiel die fabrik die politik die
statistik und die technik worte die mit
ionen enden die aktion die diskussion
die information die region und die
religion worte die mit i tät enden
nämlich zb die identität die stabilität
und die aktivität alle worte die auf
schafft enden sind auch feminin zum
beispiel die freundschaft die
gesellschaft und die mannschaft wollte
auf und sind auch feminin die bewegung
die endung die entfernung worte mit uhr
die agentur die natur die tastatur und
das wisst ihr natürlich schon endungen
mit en zeigen immer eine weibliche
person an zum beispiel eine weibliche
berufsbezeichnung wie die ärztin oder
die studentin oder auch eine weibliche
person die aus einem bestimmten land
kommt wie zum beispiel die türkin oder
die amerikanerin kommen wir jetzt zu den
namen die immer oder fast immer maskulin
sind immer maskulin
auf jeden fall worte die auf und enden
zum beispiel der lieferant der mandant
oder der migrant auch worte mit and sind
immer männlich der patient der student
der präsident ich wörter mit ich am ende
wie zum beispiel der teppich und der 40
ling der zwilling der schmetterlinge der
feigling die meisten namen die auf
renten sind auf männlich zb der lehrer
der fahrer aber nicht alle
es gibt zum beispiel auch die butter
trotzdem könnt ihr euch merken dass fast
alle mit eher männlich sind alle worte
auf ismus sind männlich der alkoholismus
der atheismus der tourismus der
rassismus endungen mit ist der
journalist der polizist alle änderungen
mit sind auch immer männlich zum
beispiel der autor der direktor oder der
motor auch immer männlich sind tage und
monate zum beispiel der montag der april
oder deren dezember fast alle wetter
elemente sind auch männlich zum beispiel
der regen oder der schnee
himmelsrichtungen sind immer männlich
der norden der süden und ganz wichtig
fast alle alkoholischen getränke sind
männlich der sekt der wein der worte
aber das hier als letztes stellen wir
euch die gruppe der neutrum wörter vor
auch hier gibt es einige regeln die ihr
euch merken könnt für worte die immer
oder fast immer neutrum sind und das
erste sind die motive also alle worte
die verkleinert werden zum beispiel
worte die auf zehn oder auch laien
sind immer dass zum beispiel das
bäumchen das häuschen das mädchen das
tischlein oder das heußlein die amish
sitzt gerade vor einem heußlein eine
endung die immer auf ein neutrum
hinweist ist mensch das argument das
dokument das element das instrument das
medikament oder das statement auch immer
neutrum sind worte die auf um enden zum
beispiel das datum das publikum das
universum
die meisten worte die auf to menden zum
beispiel das christentum das eigentum
sind auch neutrum die meisten worte die
auch mal enden sind auch neutral zum
beispiel das komme das aroma oder das
thema was immer neutral ist und
substantive werben zum beispiel das
leben das lesen oder das schwimmen
auch sind die meisten metalle neutral
zum beispiel das silber und das gold und
zu guter letzt die meist normandy mit ge
anfangen zum beispiel das gebäude das
gebirge oder das geschrei sind auch
neutral
ja das war unser video für heute und ihr
habt gesehen es gibt relativ viele
sendungen die immer einen bestimmten
geschlecht zugeordnet sind und was wir
jetzt als übung machen könnt ihr könnt
natürlich das video nochmal gucken aber
ihr könnt euch auch einfach immer
widerworte aufschreiben zum beispiel die
freiheit die sicherheit wenn wir viele
worte sammelt mit diesen änderungen dann
wisst ihr irgendwann das alles mit hide
immer ein die vor dem wort hat das war
unser kurzes video das wir noch in ghana
aufgenommen haben und nächsten sonntag
seht ihr dann ein neues video aus berlin
danke fürs zuschauen jetzt ganz wichtig
kennt die übung machen nämlich wenn ihr
ein patch hören werdet von easy german
als patron bekommt jede woche viele
übungen zu unseren themen und heute gibt
es natürlich übungen zu
artikel und wir werden mal testen wie
viele von den änderungen hier schon
gelernt habt das könnt ihr interaktiv
machen werdet jetzt einen bachelor und
abonniert easy german unbedingt gibt uns
einen daumen nach oben wenn euch das
video gefallen hat und bis bald